la violencia en las fronteras europeas
vuelve a salir a la luz gracias a una
investigación de la organización
lighthouse reports en colaboración con
los medios alemanes der spiegel y a rd
que muestra agentes de croacia golpeando
a migrantes en la frontera con bosnia
a unos 20 metros de nosotros vemos como
cuatro hombres enmascarados aparecen
entre los arbustos mientras golpean a
personas en un río profundo hasta el
pecho el río corana para forzarlos a
volver a bosnia
entre las personas agredidas y
expulsadas a la fuerza de territorio
comunitario
rechazando les el derecho internacional
a solicitar asilo se encuentran menores
de edad
alguna gente es menor sabes yo también
soy menor estas personas también son
menores no hicieron nada no les dieron
asilo lo golpearon es menor pero lo
golpearon
el ministro de interior croata ha
asegurado que penalizará a los agentes
implicados
bruselas también ha reaccionado a la
publicación
este reportaje creo que realmente daña
nuestra reputación como unión europea y
esta es una razón por la que es
extremadamente preocupante pero además
de este reportaje señala que hay
personas siendo víctimas de violencia en
nuestras fronteras externas por supuesto
si esto es verdad es totalmente
inaceptable por eso es tan importante
que esto se investigue especialmente si
hay dinero europeo implicado
y una indignación inverosímil el
tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
válido las devoluciones en caliente a
marruecos a través de las fronteras
europeas de españa en febrero de 2020
son constantes las denuncias de
violencia a las puertas de la unión
europea así como las demandas de vías
migratorias seguras según la
organización internacional para las
migraciones 22 mil 726 personas han
muerto intentando llegar a europa
cruzando el mediterráneo desde 2014
1445 en lo que va de 2021